hey yo this is benny the butcher big
brazil the bsf and checking me out on
the bootleg cave podcast
yo bullet cat podcast bootleg cab show
my guy benny the butcher hey man this is
the these are a third time appearance on
the podcast
alumni alumni show alumni gang gang gang
hey man plugs i met too is here yes sir
yes sir today
this is i think a lot of people uh you
know they assume that this is something
that you just
maybe started working on after burden of
proof but this is something you've been
had tucked right
exactly exactly this has been done like
the same time burton the proof been done
yeah because i remember we were talking
and you're like i already got everything
lined up like everything's already done
this is coming this is coming this is
coming
exactly what about the features on on it
were those like features you got
recently or was that something that
they've been tucked as well i all got
i've been got all of them joints you
know what i'm saying
especially the change joint the
the french the gem i've been had all
those i've been ready how'd you get the
chinks [ __ ] though
r.i.p i got the chinks like this
uh now this interesting story like 10
years ago
french montana and ching state was in
buffalo and i've been to like a local
rapper trying to do my [ __ ]
right right i paid i paid uh french to
come to the studio
yeah we did we did a record and chances
with them chase was like yo let me uh
let me get on this record right right
i'm like go ahead he said i got some she
said i'll let you
i spit it to you before i got some [ __ ]
i'm like go ahead
[ __ ] i learned a lot from that you know
i mean he just he see french the [ __ ]
getting paid for but he he look at it as
an opportunity you know what i'm saying
so
i learned from that that's how i got on
the royce the five nine record just he
in the studio right and i'm just right
into it
because i learned that [ __ ] from chase
that night but i told that to
uh well dj shay rest in cliche he told
that to harry
harry was like oh no [ __ ] i'm saying it
and you know what
that's damn near you know they had camp
yeah french and harry fargo go
go together like you know chinks and i'm
saying the boys coke boy so
he thought it'd be interesting to do
that and i'm like good idea
so that was um ching's vocals that harry
had had yeah harry had that
locked away somewhere you know i'm
saying he had that tucked it's the
perfect time i'm happy i got to put him
on there
it's crazy you say that so because you
i know when i'm in the studio right and
there's always like the young mc
who might not be supposed to be hopping
on the on the joint that's playing but
they writing something
just in case it's like yo i got
something to this let me get in there
that's how i do
i do that i'm writing every beat if i'm
in the studio especially if i can't get
on the [ __ ] if i know i'm not
poor i'm still gonna write
that's how you ended up on which voice
record or the one i uh
the one on tennis talk three oh [ __ ] so
that's how i mean that and that was your
record yeah
he gave it to me yeah he gave it to me
because he was doing the record i was
just sitting there
he seen me mumble he said you got
something for this i'm like yes i do and
i went
did the record he ended up letting me
had a record for the album that's crazy
how are you uh i haven't seen you since
uh obviously the shooting man and you
know you're walking around without
crutches
uh how are you feeling i'm feeling good
i'm feeling good just
getting my [ __ ] back getting the
strength back of my [ __ ] like am i
calfing in my foot and everything
and i'm seeing an injury like that take
time you know i'm sitting the hill back
from but i'm good
when that happened it was it was it was
a parking lot of walmart
or something or was it yeah in texas was
it houston or dallas it was houston
yeah like what was this like what like
like i feel like we always talk about
obviously everything i don't know
man you know i mean it was it was it was
a crazy it was some crazy
[ __ ] but some [ __ ] got up on me you
know i'm saying you know just regular
[ __ ]
is it hard cause you you move around a
lot um
is it like something like that does it
kind of
does it make you hesitant to be outside
as much
because i feel like you know you could
you could even get some like
you know ps psd from some [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah that's a fact uh
and yeah a little bit but what i'ma say
is not as much as
not more than anything else that i've
been through right you've been through
something i've been through
[ __ ] that had me like okay i need to sit
my ass down right now [ __ ] like that
so it's just more [ __ ] like that you see
you see how i'm moving around right now
i ain't gonna let that [ __ ] take over my
life and
i'm gonna move smart though you know i
mean yeah cause i had that conversation
with with conway because he you know he
told me how
how i think it was in atlanta some
somewhere where you guys were out on the
road and
and he got caught slipping and he was
like yo man that [ __ ] happened and it
kind of made me re-kind of evaluate
you know we you know i'm around rap
[ __ ] is targets we targets you know
what i'm saying especially during a
pandemic
hungry i don't even think it's no
pandemic [ __ ] i think
it's a clock thing you know what i'm
saying i think it's a cloud thing
you know cause [ __ ]
it's a rapper thing you know i mean it
ain't no like a athlete thing and they
know you know
athletes get god and [ __ ] like that you
know [ __ ] love to press up on rappers
these would be the same [ __ ] who'd be
in our face though
well we also hear about it when it
happens to a rapper i don't think we
ever hear about it that's what
that's
yeah i mean and then also too like it's
got to make you very very careful about
like
posting where you're at oh yeah i wasn't
doing no [ __ ] like that anyway
you know some people are reckless bro
there's a studio
you know what cause they don't you know
they was probably thinking like me in a
sense you know what i'm saying
uh you don't you know you know you you
you taking you're taking certain
precautions but
you gotta take every precaution you know
what i mean that type of [ __ ]
that's some real [ __ ] man that's real um
is it hard to have a you know the first
plugs i met was a classic it was uh
you know i think that that was really i
think tana talk three was like the
project that really kind of put you on
people's radars but i think plugs i met
was like the
the project that really kind of changed
your life
would you agree yeah yeah hell yeah is
it is it um
intimidating or hard to follow up and do
a sequel to something that's so
like flawed like you know it's almost
like it when nas just
still manic you know and to be honest
with you
yes it is but at the same time it's not
cause
you just gotta have a confidence in
yourself like you said you
tanner talk three in 2018 yeah
uh plugs i met one 2019
burden of proof 2020 so this is just
what i do you know what i'm saying
here exactly you know what i mean so
plugs i met two nine was just
i put the confidence in myself and you
can't you know what i mean the same
thing that's just like
an nba player going out there like damn
i he ain't thinking about is he gonna
miss the shot he's trying to take the
shot
so i just got the confidence in myself
so i'm not and i'm
really not competing against myself
because that will wreck my brain
trying to live up to tanner talk three
and or live up to the old projects i'm
just i'm just doing me getting better
you know what i'm saying
um no griselda features
on this you know i what i always look
forward to
when i when i listen to any one of
y'all's projects is there's always that
posse cut
right right it's like spurs three you
know i mean there was not that on this
project
um was that done on purpose like what
like what what was that like why no why
no conway
or gun on the album to be honest with
you like i'm happy you asked me that
because people be thinking this some
weird [ __ ] it's like [ __ ] just be
doing what they be doing
he westby over here living his life he
just had a baby just hoping i'm saying
and to be honest with you like i'm gonna
be 100 honest like
i don't even be i don't look at them
[ __ ] as like
rappers like them [ __ ] is my big
cousin so right part of me don't even
want to bother them [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying i don't think about it from
the
fan point of view like we need this on
here because guess what you're gonna get
more benny and conway and that's just
another chapter and i might and i might
subconsciously sometimes we might even
hold those back because we know the
people waiting
you know what i mean we gonna flood them
shits on i had conway on 10 to talk
three
two three times saying we're gonna flood
that [ __ ] next time or
we talking about doing a joint record
together but it's really that it's just
really
him in the midst of working on his album
i was working on burton the proof he
working on crazy [ __ ]
and we just knocking records out well
you know how fans are they're going to
come to their own conclusions
there's already been like rumors that
you guys are kind of becoming distant
and this the thing is like i think
what's happening
is what should be happening right like
you should be popping off bsf
shout out to conway he's got drum work
music exactly like you know what i'm
saying like
it just because you guys are evolving
and and
starting your own brands doesn't mean
that it's like any sort of love lost or
it ain't still griselda you know what i
mean i don't know what people be
thinking it's cause
[ __ ] be bored bro they they
they rather push
they're that narrative but they're bored
they're like yo it'd be so crazy that
people people from buffalo call me like
yo man i read that [ __ ] you and conway
i'm like what
and guess what me and kyle we had never
even speak about that [ __ ] we never even
talked about that [ __ ] cuz for what you
know what i'm saying
yeah should be crazy i think um
we're just so used as like as rap fans
we're so used to seeing our favorite rap
like clicks have some sort of
weird falling out but y'all are family
family
and and first and i'ma say this
griselda is griselda records we've never
been a group
people don't always say label we're not
never been a group we're not a group
right you know what i'm saying people
think we're a group there was a one
zelda album that was more like i look at
like a compilation
exactly that's really what it was you
know what i'm saying so you know even
though y'all got the best group of the
year bt nomination
fire fire i mean y'all did get that so
at a point it's like
we maybe we are a group but you knew you
knew you knew
cam jim and santana wasn't a group they
the dips
right you understood that they were in a
group it's the same thing with us we're
not a group
we're the gang though we the homies we
family but we're not a group so and i
know
people feel like when y'all together
y'all better we know all of that but you
know man it's nothing more than just
[ __ ] just working on their own [ __ ]
doing their own thing hey man and um
bsf had a crazy year i know you guys are
working on you guys put out the gangsta
grill [ __ ]
uh shout out to him shout out to ricky
hyde uh
but there's actually i i was just got
played some shout out to harlow he
played me some [ __ ]
you guys got a bsf album coming mm-hmm
yes sir
how many records is that uh it's like
it's give or take because we got records
but
not to say that we're keeping everything
because i'm gonna make sure
that this project is is driven
uh in a certain direction and i'm gonna
make sure it's just all crazy just and
i'm saying that i'm gonna make sure it's
balanced and everything
not saying that the last one wasn't but
i'm uh i'm saying i'm i'm going back in
the trenches doing that with this album
i was um standing with you and fred at
the uh grammy party
last week was it what was that was it
over the weekend sounds like last week
sunday was sunday or sunday and uh
hey man mm-hmm
and you guys were like let's do it and
then ghazi was sitting right there and
he's like let's go
it looked like it was going to happen
and i was like yo guys let's go
i think freddie gibbs benny the butcher
y'all gotta do the ep
right i feel like between you two and
conway
you guys are the the hardest rappers on
the planet at the moment
it's only natural that you and you and
fred have such a crazy [ __ ] chemistry
yes we do yes we do i feel like it's
gonna happen i feel like it's gonna
happen
and i mean you guys have officially
talked about it
like several times several times but
that was the best talk right there you
saying you seen the best one that felt
like that felt like it was about to
happen tomorrow
fred was sauced up he was in that pink
suit he was [ __ ]
nelly bro he was dancing to nelly yeah
freddy kane man that's freddy king yeah
so so that's something we might be able
to look forward to
man i hope so i hope so i'm gonna i'm
gonna go tap back in about that but
we're gonna see
that'll be crazy i think if you guys do
that you got to do
you got to work with one producer on it
i don't know
i don't know who it is or or a derringer
we picked alcohol missed that night
we even picked producers that night
alchemist real [ __ ] alchemist freddy
benny album ep i just need six joints
that's all even i'll take four if i'm
keeping it a buck
hey i'll say i say both eight a to be
nice
eight eight to be nice few skits 11
12 uh trackless you're you're like i
said you know
one of the greats right now who like if
anyone
that you've gotten on a record with
where you feel like i wouldn't say the
word intimidated but you feel like
the pressure's on i gotta i gotta really
have my [ __ ] together for what i'm
let you for this record um i would say
um black dog royce the five nine willie
banks
of course don q got to be on that list
yeah push
push push i'm going through the names i
could say a lot of names
that's what you know these other [ __ ]
going front like you know i mean conway
38 special uh like i i know i know i
[ __ ] with the spitters man
i know [ __ ] just coming with their
[ __ ] but they would say the same about
me though you know what i mean and
that's what it's all about
is uh keeping yourself in that type of
company uh still shopping still that's
some real [ __ ]
um you've been asked about we and you
have talked about these uh
mythological drake songs for a while i
actually heard one today
so you played me one of the drake
records today yes i did
drake just posted your [ __ ] on his
instagram fire he posted on the story of
the page
uh i don't know but he posted it he
posted the album
you did and uh [ __ ] lebron just spawned
it right
lebron just gave you some love on
twitter he said you're one of the very
few people that he gets excited when
they drop
fire fire i seen that that was dope even
for uh drake to post that [ __ ] and
stay tapped in he congratulated me on
the album i think that's dope
all the smart people i say this all the
time all the smart people
tap in early i'm saying they tapping
early
right the curators they push the culture
they tap in early have everybody else
tap in
but uh what's up with that when we when
when's the drake song coming out fam
soon i mean soon baby
soon soon i and he's got one
yeah yeah yeah yeah so he's a record
it's a dope record you know i mean i got
i got like uh
like a couple more records that i want
to put out this i'm gonna probably end
up putting out singles i got a record
with scott storch
he produced this so oh [ __ ] shout out
steve lobel i'm saying yeah shout out
steve's
my boy steve but yeah man stephen maniac
that [ __ ] got that energy like
yes he do yes he do yeah
he's still in it to run around and [ __ ]
he's still in it bro i saw him leaving
your [ __ ] last night i'm like damn steve
why do i see you everywhere and you're
like you oh g-o-g
like yeah he'd be working joints did you
get high
yo storch is like one of those guys who
smokes like crazy oh hell yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's got some [ __ ]
for me you know i brought some weed over
there
gas top i i smoke gas i got some wheat
over there he said man no you smoked
this
that type of [ __ ] um when you got the
fat joe joint because fat joe
is in my opinion one of the most slept
on mcs ever
i feel like his longevity his lyrical
ability his ability to make hit records
like
the guy's just all-time great i feel
like he i feel like you don't get enough
love
i feel like [ __ ] like him get cheated
out the love because they so great
[ __ ] like he don't count we know he's
gonna come with a hit every so he don't
count
people do that you know what i'm saying
they account you all like you don't
count because they know you they know
you're shot wet so you got like you got
like uh you know
big l big picture fat joe you got 1993
fat joe the gangster fat you got joey
crack on that [ __ ] that's what i was
looking for that's how i was looking did
you like tell him that like look man
he knew that he already knows right he
came to he came and did
he came in to brooklyn to do the record
i wasn't there but he came to brooklyn
to do the record with harry so
he he only came harry told me only came
with one other person
so he was he was ready he was ready he
was ready damn
what is uh the one thing you learned
from
the pandemic um as far as maybe just
your
like like the hustle the like like
because you know
we talked about this earlier had there
been no
restrictions you know the burden of
proof tour would have been [ __ ] crazy
stupid you know saying like i know a lot
of bags you know
i'm sure there was festivals you
probably planned on doing like all this
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
[ __ ] was loaded up but what did you
learn anything like on like like how to
kind of
move accordingly in case of [ __ ] like
you know because a lot of artists
they really depend on the road to like
get their bread because
they take those shitty advances we were
talking about earlier exactly and they
got to depend on the road to get their
money
see i'm a little different because like
we said i never took
events from a big label no [ __ ] like
that so
uh i don't rely on my money from i'm a
[ __ ] who
who where i wasn't getting 100 bands six
figures for a show and then pandemic
here i ain't getting it
i was on an incline you was going up i
was going up so it ain't like
ain't like i'm missing a million i'm
missing a few million on my salary i
miss money that i that i've never seen
anyway you know what i'm saying that i
wasn't already getting anyway so
and i mean you know we do the merge
thing you know you just drop the new
merch yes sir the merch does very well
you know what i'm saying the new design
shout out to the club bum
yeah shadow uh scruff god cat i mean
tony de niro
jake man all my my team they helped me
man jake's
had to sell me the friends of family
discount code you know what i'm saying
that's a fact that's a fact shout out to
my guy jake
um talk about your relationship with
rush he put you on the chomp uh the
chomp ep
which i thought was i'm so glad he did
that project because it was fire
he just wanted to show [ __ ] and also
you know i feel like it
showed [ __ ] like yo he
russell's like a real like rapper when
he wants to be he
he can rap better than a lot of these
[ __ ] even though he knows that
and they know that too well you know you
were supposed to go on this tour with
him
and then that didn't end up happening
because of this [ __ ] like uh
that'd have been crazy that would have
been crazy that would have been you had
so many
of my biggest moments fans and [ __ ] you
had so many little white girls that
would have never even like like singing
along with [ __ ] cocaine songs and
[ __ ]
but uh but what you how strong is your
guys
your guys's relationship because i feel
like russ is somebody who
as well as yourself uh our turn are
turning into really like independent
juggernauts i feel like
some of the knowledge that russ gives
artists for free
you know is [ __ ] that their own team
won't tell him
you know what i'm definitely picked his
brain a little bit
you know what i'm saying and we
definitely always tap in with each other
he a good dude he genuine you know i'm
saying getting his money he a
businessman first and foremost so
i like his style but definitely pick
that [ __ ] brain he's a genius
independent getting that paper
i picked his brain about a few things
how to work my iris uh how gordon bought
when he was shopping the deal so
how did you and harry fraud link harry
fraud again
very very underrated producer guy's a
monster
legend man me me me and harry link
because we had a mutual business partner
okay
you know i'm saying that who uh
connected us you know of course i know
who he was
he probably heard my name with the
gazelle the [ __ ] but they connected us
and then
it was dope vibe and good dude spent a
lot of time out there in brooklyn
recording with him
i bring my homies out there he produced
songs for uh
rick hyde that's one place too him and
shay had a good relationship so i'm
saying he's like a dude like that
how dope was uh this this year to be a
well first of all congratulations for
doing the buffalo bills song yes because
i'm an arizona cardinals fan like die
hard by the way we beat y'all hail
murray
yeah y'all murray i lost my [ __ ] mind
with it i was
sick i ain't gonna go like y'all made
the playoffs so really doesn't [ __ ]
matter but no but like
we didn't lose a game we and we went on
after that game we haven't lost
how special of a year was it to be a
buffalo guy you know because
y'all had a great year you had the i can
only imagine like as a kid if someone
would have told you like
you'll be on the 50-yard line you're
gonna have the theme song for the
buffalo bills they're gonna be in the
playoffs she was crazy man
she was crazy man shout out everybody
over there
uh k sweet you know what i'm saying ron
paul
double goolies tony daniel really hooked
that up
uh you know what i'm saying lenovo's
to daryl family everybody and i'm saying
they hooked that up for me but
man that's like uh beyond a dream come
true
beyond it there's like certain [ __ ] like
a dream come true
yeah what i'm saying because i'm a real
die-hard bills fan i don't play that
[ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] if i never done a
song if i never met nobody on the team
i'd still be going there spending my
money you know i'm saying i wouldn't
give a [ __ ] i probably would have been
made the song anyway
right but uh for us to do the merch
collab and everything for them to buy
into my brand and want to partner with
me
that says a lot and i feel like uh even
though even though
the city got a soft spot soft spot and
they hurt
for the team and owners i think that
that showed the city
like some more like you know what i mean
that's what i'm like damn they [ __ ]
with boy you know man
that was dope i mean they [ __ ] with
eastside buffalo i think that that was
dope with them and i appreciate them for
that
hey i know you're watching the interview
right now thank you for watching we got
to interrupt this for a special uh
announcement from our
good good good sponsors over at odd
socks i have all socks on my feet as we
speak
these are nwo socks you know i mean the
wolf pack you know somehow
shout out to um odd socks though if
you're watching this
go to oddssoxofficial.com and buy the
most comfortable socks in the world
and i truly do mean that these right
here these are the most comfortable
socks in the world
these are the basics they're just plain
[ __ ] great
you know they got all the licenses
spongebob wwe
just everything you could ever want yeah
i mean i'm just throwing socks at nico
blitz right now our producer is filming
this
but uh look go to oddssoxofficial.com
trust me they got the masks the boxers
everything you need my personal favorite
that i've been loving is they got the
naruto
and i'm not even into that [ __ ] but the
socks are fly and the street fighter
socks
crazy licenses odd socks official dot
com keyword
bootleg kev right now save 20 off at
checkout
josh allen or jim kelly sir are you
going to ask me that question
on tv josh allen or jim kelly
josh kelly i mean you got to kind of say
you got to kind of say jim kelly because
four four four super bowl appearances in
a row but i'd be damned if josh allen
don't look like a [ __ ]
josh alien josh allen is a stud
he's a guy when he came in he didn't
look how he looked this season but
he was showing improvement in it every
year he went he went in the offseason
and clinton where he needed to clean up
every year
and he's playing like mvp level and he
can run
and he's a dog he got hurt and that's
dope you know what i'm saying
[ __ ] uh stefan diggs bought him
an ap
you know what i'm saying so so he with
the [ __ ] yeah
yup yup and i love you and i'm happy he
there and we're gonna have a lot of good
years
when people come to the bills do they
feel like they had to have to tap in
with the team
like tapping with y'all no no not really
but let me finish though yeah that was
josh but now
jim doe jimmy's jim jim jim took it you
got to take jim right
yeah yeah yeah jim you know what i'm
saying jimmy yeah jim
uh he is buffalo
he fought tooth and nail came there
remember when jen jim
came uh he didn't even want to play he
didn't want to play in buffalo
now he lived there you know what i'm
saying he don't even want to leave he
didn't even want to come now i don't
want to leave hey four straight
that's that never happened brady ain't
brady ain't do that
i'm saying even brady ain't do that you
got to give jim hiss you would trade in
the four just for the one win though
right
like you would like of course i would
but i'm saying no
what was like what was it like to be a
bills fan with doug flutie was that but
yeah i remember when the them flew
flutie flakes
flakes i was like [ __ ] look like
somebody who works at
blockbuster you know what i'm saying a
little tiny little white dude just
[ __ ]
right but that's what buffalo is man
it's like he was like almost made for
that team in that city right
the underdog who who gonna fight you
know what i'm saying that's what jim you
gotta think
jim came in with dan marino john elway
trey and i'm saying troy aikman he came
in with those dudes
and they all got yellow jackets you know
what i'm saying
you're not in the hall of fame hell yeah
you know all the things you say that'd
be [ __ ] good
that that whole team that whole squad
thurman thomas is in the hall of fame
thurman
who was the wide receiver what's up
james lofton
andre reed what about a white dude
steve tasker who was the little white
dude that
you talking about don bibi bibi the guy
who who was running and yeah yeah the
cowboys
caught up with him yup yup yup he ended
up going to green bay and winning one
damn right right he said he said he felt
bad
when he won that one hey who's your
favorite rapper
like right now not a time at all times
oh right now right now right now
now i'm somebody like right i got rap
birds i listen to right now give me like
three that aren't signed to you
i wasn't gonna say nobody excited to me
i'm gonna tell you what i'd be listening
to
i'm saying what i'd be listening to i'm
listening to uh remember the time by
kodak that song that's my [ __ ]
okay uh i'm always i'm listening to meek
all the time i listen to a lot of meek
uh you and meek mill wouldn't happen to
have any music together would you yes we
do oh okay yes we do yes we do
shout out to chasers uh what else
who else i'm listening to i listen to a
little baby
42 doug uh
that's what type of [ __ ] i'll be
listening to i'll be listening to trap
music what'd you say
oh yeah that's like my theme song
that's like my theme song when i want to
get on my [ __ ] and i'm with my [ __ ]
we all got our [ __ ] on we recession
proof yo yo gotti is low-key like one of
the hardest
bosses in hip-hop history like all his
artists
he wants to actually be bigger than
himself you know most of these
[ __ ] they'll sign somebody
and their their ego will get in the way
of their rights right you know
ross has done a good job of not being
that way exactly but uh but guys daddy
did it definitely did a good job
you're a person to learn from too yeah
you ever tapped in with gotti
i met him at the roc nation brunch we
didn't get to uh tap in hit boy
introduced us and [ __ ]
shout out to hit boy hey speaking of hit
boy you just want a grammy for
for king's disease i told him i say
you're a walking [ __ ] grammy that's
what i told him
the other day man i texted him how close
i mean your album had to be considered
for the
for the like it had to be in the running
it came out a month late
before they could go okay okay okay uh
your [ __ ] came out you could be in
discussion for for next year but you
know i'm saying it is what it is
no of course i had to have it i'd give
that [ __ ] to my mom or some [ __ ] like
that
you know to talk my [ __ ] to drag my nuts
but you know what i'm saying you know
that you don't
you know what i mean yeah now i think uh
for like like i was with freddy all day
on sunday and
you know he lost even i think he should
have one shout out shout out to nas but
i think
alfredo was the album of the year but i
think it's like
just coming from like an independent
like lyrical background i feel like
this year's nominations you can say
whatever you want about him like i think
a little baby should have probably
been in that conference but it was all
dope [ __ ] rap music
like royce got a nomination that shit's
crazy like
you know what i mean and russia is crazy
but roy's one of my favorite mcs ever
as someone who like i feel like i feel
like they at least kind of like
uh got the nominations right besides a
little baby
yeah i think a little baby or rottie
could have been in that yeah right
too but they only could have they should
have just nominated everybody why don't
we only gave a certain amount of
nominees
five nominees say you can't put a number
on nominees
so what that mean you got to put the
[ __ ] that deserve it sometimes
[ __ ] might it might be eight nominees
one year album of the year what you
gonna do
i don't know would you and uh i mean
you're you're you're doing a sequel to
the plugs i met would you and hit boy uh
get back together i know you guys got
some records
out burn the proof too yeah that'd be
crazy
has it been discussed it has to have
been i mean you guys i know you guys got
it
that haven't been specifically discussed
but it's been discussed
lock in what we doing lock in ah you
know what i'm saying let's go so
burn the proof too i like hit boy
because you could go over there and
you'll never know who's around and then
like
you get like random like there's been so
many random records like asap ferg's on
a nas song because
you know it's just just like it's that
environment it's that type of
environment boy studio has that
it's got that like every like you know
everybody's
it's just it's just a good spot shout
out to hitboy um
okay so you're gonna start dropping
singles
drake songs coming out soon yes
that's uh yo when you do obviously you
had to pay drake right it was a little
swap
that was for love yeah yeah he didn't i
mean he he not
i mean he ain't like asking for [ __ ]
to pain i don't know how the business go
when the song come out
right right but but you ain't have to do
the like i don't even think you could
buy a drake feature for the record right
i think he's doing what he wants to do
right he's just doing what he want to do
and
because if you want if you're working
with who he who he chooses to work at at
this point
at this point in his career working with
who he feel is dopamine well he feels
wavy so
like i said his dope for duels like that
even russ hit boy to reach to a [ __ ]
like me you know what i'm saying but
you know he's not he's not i mean i'm
pretty sure if if you got that bag and
like yo i need you on this i got this of
course he a hustler you're gonna take it
but he just i mean he's just curating
right now i mean
um talk about the
shows in la it was right before
everything shut down that was like the
last thing i did was go to those shows
it was going crazy i mean we was at the
meet and greet we had they were telling
us okay no more dapping at the meeting
right like she was getting real you were
selling like 500
aprons or something i remember i was
going up to the merch booth and
everything was sold out except for what
was like it was an apron like a bloody
apron
there was like one bloody apron left or
so much was it how much was the apron
it was i was like damn the only thing
that's left is 200
jesus christ but um but that was the
show when uh you know
uh conway did the cow was crying and hoe
was standing on the side of the stage
and [ __ ] like
um how crazy was that night that jay-z
came to that because that that seemed
like one of them moments
that's like pivotal for the crew you
know what i'm saying even though you
guys were already
gang dealt you know what with roc nation
and [ __ ] but like that that seemed like
a
one of them nights like when y'all do
your documentary one day
it'll be it was it was something there
it was it was
just doing the show knowing big dog
standing there watching and [ __ ] like
that
coming through support and showing that
he approved him and e yeah him emery
came through though
it just left the bucks lakers game yep
and that's what i seen i'm like
it was right across the street and they
just stopped by you know what i mean so
it was definitely like you know i mean
we on our [ __ ] he congratulated [ __ ]
the next day like yo y'all killed that
so
i feel like the inevitable has to be jay
getting on a record with benny
that's inevitable that'd be crazy and
that'd be crazy
is is that something that i mean you
don't ask for something like that it's
almost like the drake thing like if he
wants to do it he'll do it type [ __ ]
right
right right right right i asked though
you did ask
yeah but that's nothing you could really
ask for you know what i'm saying i
should have worked that into the
management
like look i'm a sign but i need i need
one i need one jay first i need that i
need a 16 of him talking about selling
cocaine right but i understand and i'm
saying of course i want a whole verse
but i'm not gonna lie i understand that
his door is open to us right so i
understand that
it's some knowledge and certain [ __ ]
that i'm a
game that could be just as valuable you
know what i'm saying
like all of them the deal with the nfl
i knew that before it happened you know
i'm saying uh
the what's your name i was in the rock
nation building somebody told me it's
like yeah watch what happened thursday
and then that square [ __ ] yeah you know
what i'm saying so yeah that [ __ ] was
crazy
i mean so like it's like he he
before he did the nfl deal that was the
day that i signed my contract
so he had to chop it up with us and then
we went to go do that so he was
explaining it to us so his door is open
you know what i'm saying so
it's a lot to be gained i mean i'll be
one i don't be wanting
him to feel that that i just want and i
mean that i'm that type i just want the
song i want the song
cause it ain't like that of course i
would take the [ __ ] so you
you asked for the song what what would
they tell you
nah i i examined so what did it what did
emery tell you
uh what did he say what did the whole
tell me
i think he was i think he was going out
of town i have one time i have flu out
here he had an idea
of a song that he wanted to do with me
and i flew out here to do the song with
him
you know what i'm saying but he was
moving around and doing [ __ ] you know
i'm saying you know that's
that's the [ __ ] president time stamp
so what happened so he you flew out here
to do a song with him yeah he had the
idea for so what was the idea
i i never got to chop it up it was like
yo hit me like yo could you be out here
he said he got an idea i'll say yeah i
come out there
that's like one of those things you
don't even think twice you're just like
i'm getting on the plane what happens
what i did i would have been driving a
car down the highway just all right
guys what happened in the sprinter damn
i mean but but
but even for for him to have an idea you
know i mean if we never do nothing
that's still crazy to me you know what
i'm saying that would be insane that
would be it would sound crazy i'm gonna
be honest
and if hove get on the song with me
hold on he gonna give you that aesthetic
of what the what what he feel like
the people want to hear on some street
[ __ ] i believe because
i analyzed it because you know i i sat
down and thought about my jay-z feature
a few times okay look when he get on
them songs with
with jeezy the push of [ __ ] the drug
dealer's anonymous
he's going in he's going here that's
what i'm trying to say so i feel like
you've been thought about like this i've
been thought about that you know what
i'm saying i feel like he'd come on some
[ __ ] like that
and it'd be crazy yeah that would be
that'd be wild
um you mentioned earlier you and conway
obviously always mean fam
et cetera like um but you kind of skated
over the
you know we got might do a project
together everybody's been asking for
that
like you guys got to have at least a
project's worth of music in the can
together
um we got some records but no
because we got a project we got projects
worth for music together like i got a
first i got a verse i got to do for him
right now
i'm saying some [ __ ] that he sent me i
got a verse that i gotta do send it to
me like a week ago i gotta knock it out
for him
i'm saying so like we always sending
[ __ ] i'm on his [ __ ] he's gonna be on my
[ __ ] so
it's like we know we just need to lock
in for
three days three four days comfortably
man
conway is an alien that's all i'm saying
man you could be cheating it's crazy
that
i think you'd be cheating you guys are
like cold it's like you guys are like
the
[ __ ] nets bro like and they could be
cheating cheat cold with that [ __ ] he
rap like a [ __ ] computer
it's crazy terminator 3. is is he
somebody who
like like did you learn a lot who was
who who do you think i mean obviously
when you you know when griselda was
first starting to step out and do the
freestyles
you were like you were just benny you
know what i mean
so did has conway taught you like a like
like
like any things that you've built built
on throughout the years just like when
it comes to this rap and [ __ ]
or did you guys always just kind of
learn from each other man
yeah i've been around them [ __ ] since
i was a kid
so i learned more from i learned more
than i learned a lot in the past few
years since people been seeing this but
[ __ ] did i learn from that [ __ ] i
learned by the time i was 18.
wow you feel what i'm saying like real
[ __ ] and i'm just
as he learning more i'm learning more
what i'm saying from him and wes
you know what i'm saying but hell yeah
it's like specifically
uh i remember when i first when i was
working on tanner talk three he maybe
heard a couple of the tracks and he was
like yo
just do you he said don't worry about
trying to don't get caught up in doing
what me and wes do
just do you relax dude i don't know what
he heard i felt like the song was just
fire or whatever but
he probably heard something but but i
understand what he was trying to say and
i'm saying so
he had a [ __ ] like that who gonna come
with his advice and [ __ ] like that
and then on the on the executive side
you
doing black soprano family bsf
what have you taken from what what uh
what westside gun is
because you know he's got a crazy shot
boldy james i mean he's been
armani caesar he's been putting together
an amazing roster
and he's so dope about just the
aesthetic of
the crew facts like i feel like that's
kind of
people a lot of people might [ __ ] with
with y'all [ __ ] they but they just [ __ ]
with with the gear and [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying that's a fact that's a
fact and just the vibe like
you know what i mean um but what what
what have you gotten from from gun that
you're applying now to your [ __ ]
just do it just do it you see the [ __ ]
that he doing [ __ ] in paris
the [ __ ] doing this [ __ ] doing that
you know has a great car collection
yes you do does he do i say every time i
open my [ __ ] phone it's like this
will got a red something
you got some [ __ ] you got a [ __ ] man
truck
buzz got the fleet but man i just
learned from just
just doing it you know i mean open just
opened up a store buffalo kids store in
the mall
walden gallery in buffalo like you said
signing artists running around doing
this doing that we did the movie
just do it say you could do it if it's
in reach do it like what the [ __ ] you
waiting for
where are you ranking um the movie
amongst
other classics such as like let's talk
about like you know kill a season
maybe maybe shot this you know uh i'm
ranking it i'm making it i'm ranking the
top 10
irene conflict the top ten what's your
favorite like rap movie
and i don't mean rap movie isn't like
crush grooving [ __ ] i mean like you know
let's go like 97 and up like there's
there's a lot of dope rap movies
i don't know 97 and up
in full shits you know what i'm saying
valley was belly
yeah all of them [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying you got to watch some [ __ ] over
and over we watch them [ __ ] right now
i'm sure that'll come on you
wouldn't change your channel i always
tell everyone belly is
the best worst movie ever a word because
it's like
it's like when you read when you watch
it when you're like 15 like me i was 15
never by rough riders and [ __ ] i'm like
this the greatest movie of
all time but then when you're like 30
and you re-watch it you're like
this storyline was kind of shitty if
we're just being honest
but the visuals were so that's what it
was real like
hype williams i wish you would have kept
making movies because i think that's the
only movie you ever did and then belly
too came out with the game and then that
[ __ ] was
that [ __ ] was trash yeah the game yeah
the
uh the [ __ ] uh the belly two [ __ ]
right belly two was horrific
i seen that i heard people say that then
i seen the [ __ ] you saw it you actually
watched it i watched like 30 minutes
i was like i can't do this man this
ain't badly no i watched you
are you gonna act more hell yeah i was
taking acting classes and all that
damn i'm on my [ __ ] i'm taking i'm i'm
what's harder rapping or acting
um acting
acting cause i'm being me in front of
that mic
i got to be somebody i got to be
somebody else in front of a camera
they might just start type casting you
though as like you know that that like
the [ __ ] drug dealer in every movie
which would be a nice career to have no
i wouldn't mind that i wouldn't mind
that
that one what's that mexican that's in
every movie the bald guy
he's on he's in [ __ ] next he's a
fright after next he and everything
and everything like they just this guy's
whole career is just being i'm playing a
[ __ ] i'm playing a doctor next
time
i'm playing some [ __ ] but that's what
i'm saying i might do i might do a
a romantic movie next time you're gonna
do are you gonna do a rom-com
i might because my [ __ ] independent i'm
waiting for scripts i'm not waiting
i don't gotta go to netflix and no [ __ ]
like that i'm a we're going to fund a
movie by ourselves oh you're going to
start doing your own movies hell yeah
that's what we did we conflicted i know
what i'm saying like
is that something that's like going to
be like a thing now man they the people
like it they [ __ ] with it and i can't
stop if i wanted to they want to see me
in more films
damn so right that's what i was saying i
had to get ready you had to be in it
more
yeah take some acting classes get my
[ __ ] right yeah i feel like you could
have been in it more
yeah i know i feel like i feel like that
was good that they that what happened to
uh
bust down the brick nick because people
know me i was a familiar face in the
movie and people was attached to me
so right in the middle of a movie we
[ __ ] your emotions up he out of here
like [ __ ] like damn that's
benny i think it reminds me like
do you remember like back in the day any
time a rapper
would have like a cameo in a movie
they'd put him on the cover
like he probably was on there and you
know yeah blockbuster and you'd be like
oh [ __ ] nas is in this movie called
ticker what is this and then you rent it
and he's in it for like three minutes
and you're like what the [ __ ] is this
did you ever watch that knives movie no
that was a real movie
it's called ticker it's like uh i forget
the guy's name in it but it's yeah it's
a mic it's the most random [ __ ]
he was on the cover yeah he was on the
cover oh [ __ ] like he was really up in
that
bag he must have man he must have
all right so the rest of the year last
time you were you kind of laid out
everything and then we got to this point
we could do it let me see what's going
on what's going on the rest of the year
the rest of the year
we got rick high album coming next i'm
saying he's killing it yup we got place
two coming next
he killed that [ __ ] uh survivor's
remorse and then
uh he's gonna put some [ __ ] out uh
you never know like you said you never
know a freddie gibbs
benny album you never know my schedule
is my schedule is clear
i'm saying my schedule is clear so we
never know
i'm definitely putting something out by
the end of the year definitely
definitely
that's why i had to get i had to get
this out at the top of the year because
i'm on my way
again well uh the album is out
yeah this drake song should be coming
out soon when that when something like
that happens
is that like uh
are you still independent or does that
go through his [ __ ]
well just a drake song cause he'll be
hopping on he hopped on he'd be having a
hardest [ __ ] and then and then all of a
sudden it's throw ovo
he'll be like wait but there's something
like like a one-off or something you
ain't got to the paperwork i'm assuming
no we ain't get to that [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying but however it go i'm
pretty sure that's why i said
i'm pretty sure that it's gonna run
smooth but i'm gonna drop that
this year i'm gonna drop some more like
a whole album this year
how many records would the meet do you
have oh we got one record
one we got one is that is that yours not
this his record oh it is
oh right this is right yeah yo you've
been on a lot of people's [ __ ]
i feel like right now you're like the
the
the like dope rapper every every artist
is like yo
i gotta do like i gotta have a spitter
on my [ __ ] let me
let me see what's up with benny yeah
yeah i feel like i've seen you uh
weren't you on like ti's album yeah yeah
yeah yeah just like random [ __ ] like
that's like oh [ __ ] benny's on this
mm-hmm mm-hmm shout
yeah what's been the most random feature
you've done of notoriety that
maybe you wouldn't have expected to
shout out denzel kirby you heard that
[ __ ] i'm gonna
[ __ ] die remix that she's crazy uh
not that's not the random one
denzel crazy a random one random one
what the [ __ ] i don't know some [ __ ] i'm
trying to think of like
the artist people know but i don't know
but i'm gonna be working with a whole
bunch of different [ __ ] anyway
is um like a benny verse purchasable
yeah okay oh yeah so some guy
some dope boy in indianapolis indiana
right now is watching this and he's like
i got this [ __ ] bag i want i want a
benny record
he can buy it yes he can how much does
that cost let's do a little
advertisement
let's let's camera look let's go okay so
we're gonna we got two options we got
the major label price
and then we got the independent dope boy
price what so give me the two prices
um 20k
20k 20k will you do the video or is that
actually you got to put it
another 20k so 40 000.
if you're in whatever city and you want
a [ __ ]
benny verse get it to homie tony give it
to homie tony
get in harlem i have two money chase get
that ben
get at me and if you want the video it's
40.
yeah 40. these prices these prices are
negotiable
will you take bitcoin yeah do you own
any bitcoin
no i feel like i jumped i ain't jumping
that [ __ ]
man you [ __ ] everybody be telling me to
jump in that angel bro
every time someone's told you to jump on
it you should have cause it's like 60
bands right now
it were for one in the pandemic it got
down to like thirty seven hundred
dollars a coin
and now it's six this was all excited
yep i got sick
trust me i know what i'm saying trust me
i got some other [ __ ] though all right
what are you
like like do you have um any sort of
things you invest in like maybe
we got the sports agency you tell me
about the sports team got the sports
agency big sports because that hasn't
gone that hasn't gone well for
other rappers i had ricky williams in
here last week and he was telling me
about the no limit [ __ ] because he was
signing no limit
so like i feel like the only person
who's really pulled it off pulled it off
has been
hov okay this is how you it's different
uh
levels to the [ __ ] it's contracts and
it's marketing okay right now we're
doing marketing
right let me explain this now we we
teaming up
with players and athletes and and
and connecting them with brands that
they usually wouldn't connect with
because
these local brands would want to do
business with these athletes right so
you don't got to be michael jordan to
get a commercial
you for what i'm saying and these and
these athletes is hustlers just like we
is you know what i'm saying
they gotta get it while they can they're
gonna make fifty thousand a hundred
thousand here and i'm saying they down
to do that
virus market and everything like that
you know what i mean and uh
and you know when kova uh break it it'll
be a little better but we we're doing
things like that you know what i'm
saying we just we just did something
lamar odom i could talk about that right
yeah we just did something with lamar
odom and i'm saying shout out lamar
what's up with lamar odom man tell me
man he cool man he came through the
video man
harlem and his homeboy brought him
through man i [ __ ] with i [ __ ] with
older man real so
is he one of your clients oh see that's
the thing like we
we or are they to do the marketing
uh both both you could have if you're
not locked in with a contract like we
could come and we could come get you
some paper we could work freelance for
you
and we just take our percentage what is
the like inspiration to get involved
in that i mean you're obviously a big
sports guy as am i but
to kind of officially dip your toe into
something like that that's like
that's a hard uh business i feel like i
know i know i know it's a higher
business i have plenty talks
but that's what we do man we we in it
for that and i got a uh
my man ron you know what i'm saying he
was he had a sports agency for 25 years
so he's he's he's doing it with you what
i'm saying he in our corner he
he's giving us all the game we have
several meetings with him i'm gonna go
uh chop it with og one too
you know what i'm saying roc nation
sports so you know those and i'm saying
so
trust me i'm equipped which which is
there any athletes like that you guys
are like pretty locked in with that you
work with um
on like a regular basis uh we we really
just started it we're really just
getting the website up and everything
but
i mean what's going on with lamar odom
you guys have been trying to bring his
ass back
i'm gonna be doing work with like brad
sims writer yeah you know what i'm
saying henrik harley
you and i'm saying shout out my [ __ ]
dion dawkins for the bills you know what
i'm saying
all the bills got to tap in bro yeah
yeah yeah you know what i mean
yeah and i'm trying to tell you like
even even like you guys just signed
emanuel sanders right
that's crazy right he's gonna come in
handy for like seven million dollars i
got a feeling i'm gonna be back on that
50-yard line again cole beasley emmanuel
sanders
slash stefan dick and john brown
slashing through the field for 17 weeks
hey that's a crazy four wide
bro don't think is john brown still
there he was a free agent right now
he left i don't think he's signed
anywhere yet did he
who signed john brown hey john brown is
a homie man
you quick super quick all right man well
look the album is out uh go get that
[ __ ]
support it the merch is going crazy how
do you keep the merch in stock like
we don't the slight the site probably up
like three four days out the month
we make drops like that sometimes we we
skip months you know i'm saying we keep
it
very very limited very premium you know
i mean yeah you can go buy a pyrex
uh jar signed by you on your website or
candles i i got candles yeah you got the
candles
the plugs i met two candles i got uh
what else we got we got shirts of course
we got hats
we got sign scales we got signed pyrex's
uh signed scales and signed pyrexes i'm
doing rubber bands necks
doing my pack of rubber bands next wait
you're doing your own rubber bands yeah
oh [ __ ] drug paraphernalia drug
paraphernalia
hey shout out to crack you know what i
mean do we talk about you just talking
about crack you know what i mean
crack always rear his head in the
conversation somewhere man somewhere
gotta be fire no real [ __ ]
appreciate you baby you know what i mean
the plugs i made too ah